yannick jadot vous dit ce sont les
chasseurs qu'ils ont et crée la
surpopulation de certains animaux les
nourrissons et ce sont les agriculteurs
qui paye les dégâts marine le pen dit
les chasseurs jouent un rôle social de
régulation des espèces dans notre pays
alors bien entendu vous êtes très très
opposés sur ce sujet je sais que c'est
un sujet qui fait énormément débat vous
allez voir un là sur les réseaux sociaux
ça va être un déferlement là-dessus
vraiment énormément de gens ou un avis
là dessus et un avis très divergents
j'ai fait de nombreux débats là dessus
et c'est vrai que voilà c'est un sujet
important
yannick jadot vous avez travaillé à ce
que je vois en tout cas vous avez ramené
nombreux fils que ce que vous avez à
dire à marine le pen sur ce sujet sur
lequel vous avez vraiment deux avis très
divers
merci on va évidemment discuter comment
vous aimez les chats mais vous soutenez
les chasseurs comment vous aimez les
animaux et vous soutenez la l'élevage le
plus industriel et le plus dur pour les
animaux mais un point avant si vous
permettez
la question c'est au fond quel intérêt
servez vous madame le pen en 2017 quand
vous avez fait votre campagne ya cinq
ans vous étiez financé par les russes
par poutine vous avez en récompense
notamment du soutien que vous aviez
apporta bladimir poutine dans l'annexion
de la crimée dans le dernier tract que
vous deviez faire vous deviez mettre
votre photo avec vladimir poutine
allié très bien vous l'avez garder ce
qui montre à quel point au fond vous
êtes visionnaire en termes de politique
étrangère c'est votre ami
c'est l'international des nationalistes
et en fait c'est quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui commet des atrocités des
crimes de guerre en ukraine simplement
parce que les ukrainiennes et les
ukrainiens ou défendre leur liberté et
la démocratie et d'un côté vous soutenez
poutine et comme lui vous voulez
l'effondrement de l'union européenne
l'affaissement de l'union européenne
pour qu'on n'ait pas les moyens de peser
face aux dictatures face aux puissances
économiques face aux grands groupes
multinationaux et quand vous parlez de
la france au fond vous la diviser vous
stigmatisez toute une partie de la
population et finalement à vouloir
rester en repli en enfermement et en
vassalisation vis-à-vis des dictatures
vis-à-vis de poutine en réalité vous
êtes la candidate de l'anti france vous
êtes la candidate du déclassement de la
france est finalement de son effacement
alors maintenant on peut parler
j'aimerais avoir une réponse novatrice
que ça c'est vrai que c'est un sujet il
marine le pen pas un sujet simple si
vous deveniez sur les réseaux sociaux
tout le monde se posait la question que
yannick jadot vous pose ce soir et
voulait aborder ce sujet avec ou non
mais très clairement vous tromper
totalement monsieur jadot ah bon la
réalité c'est que j'ai toujours défendue
je crois une vision gaullienne de la
france et de la diplomatie française
c'est à dire la l'indépendance
l'équidistance et la constance et on le
sait très bien tous les présidents de la
république ont tenté peu ou prou plutôt
plus ou moins bien d'ailleurs de
maintenir justement 7,7 et coup distance
avec toutes les grandes puissances que
sont la chine que sont la russie
évidemment que sont les états unis nous
avait coûté le jeu ne regarde je vais
écouter le discours de chacun dans 61
les soviets attaqué berlin et qu'il
fallait que on nous soyons unis pour
défendre la démocratie donc là vous êtes
à équidistance entre les populations
civiles du grain bombardé et vladimir
poutine c'est vous le savez très bien
car à partir du moment où venir poutine
a envahi d'ukraine j'ai immédiatement
qu'on ait ça pour une raison simple j'ai
le dos et que moi je suis cohérente moi
je défends la souveraineté des nations
et l'intégrité mais là du territoire il
fallait je les fais quand la mairie car
si pas leur liberté mais ne me coupe pas
parle ça sert à rien on aura le temps de
se parler je les fais quand les
américains ont envahi l'irak masson et
je le fais quand la russie envahi
d'ukraine je veux dire de la manière la
plus claire qui soit mais vous êtes
aucune difficulté avec la photo d'un
dictionnaire de la cité qui a bombardé
les populations civiles en syrie qui a
rasé grosse nick jusque là ça vous pose
aucun problème si j'adore ziza
présidente de la république bien quand
on est président de la république
française il faut être capable de parler
à tous y compris à vladimir poutine dont
vous met une photo de lui non non
monsieur gilles longtemps vous avez
soutenu vladimir poutine jadot j'ai lu
ma soutenir tous les dirigeants
politiques que j'ai vu et rencontrer et
d'ailleurs monsieur jadu vous verrez
qu'il y a également la photo avec le
premier ministre polonais qui n'est pas
particulièrement un ami de vladimir
poutine ça vous a pas échappé mais ça
c'est ça ça vaut les listes ça reste
aussi un populiste qui se bat contre
l'avortement qui se bat contre les
homosexuels en pologne
pour le peuple ukrainien non il
accueille 700 milles ukrainien on est
d'accord d'accord merci de lui accorder
très bien est ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'en fait les personnes que vous mettez
en photo raconte votre projet politique
est un projet politique et fauqué - pour
défendre la france et sa capacité à
rayonner dans le monde qui est moins
pour défendre une france puissante dans
une europe forte mais qui est plutôt
l'international des nationalistes et
c'est pas la défense de la france ni des
français dont on va pouvoir parler
d'ailleurs de qui a créé la dépendance
de la france avec la russie parce que
permettez moi de vous dire que dans ce
domaine les verts ont une très lourde
responsabilité
bien sûr monsieur j'adore mais enfin en
défendant la fin du nucléaire en
défendant l'éolien de manière
parfaitement irresponsable vous défendez
l'ouverture de centrales à charbon et de
centrales à gaz mais bien sûr et du coup
les verts allemands qui sont les
responsables de l'effondrement du
nucléaire en allemagne sont les
responsables de la dépendance non
seulement de l'allemagne au gaz russe
mais également de l'ensemble de l'europe
au gaz evault et vous avez vos amis
polonais aussi vous avez vous savez nous
sommes les seuls c'est une dame le pen
moi je nous sommes les seuls au niveau
européen à avoir combattu le fait par
exemple que le gaz soit reconnue comme
une énergie verte parce que nous
combattons depuis tant d'années à la
fois la dépendance au gaz la dépendance
au pétrole parce que c'est le
dérèglement climatique
il s'éloigne prendrait elle a dit un
truc important on va rester sur
l'allemagne non maintenant il se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans une situation
très délicate mais tout le monde tout
je suis la demande par timan parti
gagnera il n'y a pas que l'allemagne moi
ce que je veux aujourd'hui c'est
construire le grand plan
d'investissements européens parce qu'on
a besoin de l'europe jeu te ment pour
sortir des dépendance aux énergies
fossiles c'est dramatique du point de
vue du climat on voit que ça tue la
démocratie et de toutes les compétences
politiques dont vous avez fait partie
madame le pen vis-à-vis des dictateurs
et vis-à-vis des dictateurs qui essayent
de nous tenir à la gorge avec le gaz et
le pétrole et moi ce que je veux c'est
qu'au fond on investit ce qu'on réunisse
tous les acteurs du bâtiment tous les
acteurs du bâtiment et on met le paquet
sur l'isolation des logements des
français on met le paquet sur les
bâtiments ça réduit notre consommation
de gaz c'est comme ça que c'est un
sortir ça il ya eu un jour est-ce que je
suis attendu que c'est faisable sa
gestion un cerveau mais ça fait à
ramener 15 ans que les gouvernements ne
le font pas vous savez une maison vous
la rénover j'étais encore avec une
famille il ya quelques jours deux mille
euros de factures de chauffage quand ils
ont rénové leur logement eh ben ils sont
passés à 800 euros 1200 euros
d'économisés parents et ça réduit notre
dépendance à poutine sur les énergies
renouvelables
là vous avez un problème c'est qu'en
fait aujourd'hui si on veut remplacer
rapidement le gaz c'est pas en
construisant des centrales nucléaires il
va nous falloir 20 ans pour le faire
c'est en développant massivement des
énergies renouvelables moi je propose
qu'on mette du photovoltaïque par
exemple sur tous les toits plats les
parkings les supermarchés les écoles
c'est une électricité pasche importés de
chine a besoin importés de chine quand
on est au parlement européen madame le
pen quand on était en parlement européen
semble vous savez que c'est moi qui ai
mené le combat contre le dumping chinois
he d'accord mais sur les panneaux photos
feraient d'ailleurs mais il arrive des
chaînes cm en fait aujourd'hui j'adore à
la raison
annoncé aujourd'hui le faire vous avez
heureusement des oreilles françaises qui
le font moi je me bats pour que nos
marchés publics aillent sur les
entreprises françaises et européennes
je suis déçu ce plan de sécurité
énergétique et de sécurité pour ça faut
sortir des compétences et pour ça faut
pas rigoler sur le christ a dit agir
monsieur jadot permettez moi de vous
dire que je pense que vous avez porté un
modèle qui est un modèle en même temps
le plus destructeur de la planète
mais en même temps ces colons
qui crée oui un plus de dépendance en
réalité aux puissances extérieures à
huit modèles c'est le modèle allemand il
ya vingt ans vous avez imposé votre
modèle en allemagne d'ailleurs vos amis
sont au gouvernement depuis pour
l'électricité un d'accord donc j'ai
regardé un ça a coûté 500 milliards 1
les éoliennes les panneaux solaires etc
et en l'occurrence ça pollue six fois
plus que la france c'est à dire sept
cent pour cent fois plus que la france
est et en plus c'est 70% plus chers pour
les entreprises et pour les parties
madame le donc pour moi c'est un échec
total
c'est un essai l'ue en matière de
pouvoir d'achat c'est un échec en
matière évidemment environnementale
puisque sa peau lieu encore une fois six
fois plus qu'en france non madame le pen
on va pas on va plus on se retrouve
aujourd'hui maintient aujourd'hui même
le nom mais c'est un sujet intéressant
l'annoncé présentes ont surtout deux
réacteurs nucléaires qui reste en
allemagne ont produit plus d'électricité
que les 30000 éoliennes allemandes
madame l'om et vous savez très bien ils
ont des chances yanina ils sont en train
de nous développer
sans mille emplois mais c'est moi j'ai
la force de l'allemagne c'est qu'ils ont
une industrie moi j'aimerais bien qu'on
aurait dit que j'adore d'industrie en
france qu'ils ont encore en allemagne il
ya dans ce qu'ils ont su défendre un
tissu industriel qu'ils ont su gagner
janot bernise et l'allemagne a bien le
mans une grande industrie l'allemagne
actuellement et on le voit que c'est
c'est avec ce qui se passe en ukraine
c'est extrêmement compliqué pour eux
mais c'est tout mais surfer sur le net
c'est plus compliqué sur la présence
monsieur hanouna aujourd'hui pourquoi
est ce que on paye l'électricité aussi
très très chers c'est parce qu'on a
treize réacteurs nucléaires en france
qui sont à l'arrêt qui sont en
maintenance parce que ils sont là les
nos réacteurs vieillissent ils sont en
maintenance ils ont des défauts ils
vieillissent la seule question c'est la
question qu'on va se poser pour la
france madame le pen c est ce que comme
emmanuel macron ont construit de
nouveaux repères pour remplacer les
vieux et on aura des opère en 2040 2045
faut juste expliquer aux français
comment on gère aujourd'hui leur pouvoir
d'achat comment gères le climat et comme
angers à la dépendance vis-à-vis de la
russie ou c'est mon projet on investit
sur la maîtrise de l'énergie sighvi ça
fait gagner de l'argent aux français sur
leur pouvoir d'achat et effectivement on
déploie les énergies renouvelables que
tous les pays sont en train de
développer parce qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
les énergies les moins chers et qui sont
de fait des neiges sont par exemple vous
expliquer qu' énormément de gens qui
disent que l'allemagne a été planté à
cause de leur dû des balades de la
fermeture de nombreuses centrales mais
aujourd'hui je vous dis pas je vous dis
pas qu'il ya peint une différents
problèmes en allemagne et dans le reste
de l'europe je vous dis pas le contraire
la transition énergétique allemande ça a
été de réduire le nucléaire de réduire
le charbon d'augmenter les énergies
renouvelables et ils ont maintenu leur
dépendance au gaz c'est vrai mais la
force de l'allemagne aujourd'hui c'est
qu'elle décide d'en sortir et moi je
veux un pays qui soit capable savez
quand on a fait le nucléaire en france
dans les années sont dit on a été
capable de faire la plume des plus
grandes politique industrielle de notre
histoire qu'a montré que quand on a la
volonté on peut on a construit en 20 ans
58 réacteurs on a mis beaucoup d'argent
public on a formé les meilleurs
ingénieurs les meilleurs techniciens les
meilleurs ouvriers au monde sauf
qu'aujourd'hui
notre parc il est vieillissant est ce
qu'on continue
est-ce que vous continuez à investir
dans des e p1 qui coûte 20 milliards il
n'est pas fini dix ans de retard 20
milliards c'est ça votre projet moderne
industriels et ben moi je préfère faire
comme le reste du monde investir dans
des énergies renouvelables s'est pas
risqué c'est pas cher et ça crée de
l'emploi sont notés marine rien tout ça
est totalement faux je voudrais bien moi
ce que je voudrais dire aux gens qui
nous regardent qu'est-ce qu'il faut
souvent vous passez sur l'autoroute et
vous voyez les éoliennes eh bien elles
sont à l'arrêt la prochaine fois vous
verrez quand elle soins et bien quand
elles sont à l'arrêt il faut que vous
sachiez que ce sont des centrales à gaz
et des centrales à charbon qui tourne
pour vouloir offrir justement les
lectrices madame le pen ses nerfs
chambon elle en place
me dit tu les as mal charbon remplacent
les centrales nucléaires qui sont
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt vous me dites les
allemands ont baissé leur paie leur
consommation de charbon c'est faux les
allemands en 2019 consommer plus de
charbon ce qu'en 2009 est d'ailleurs
sous le mandat des mairies pour les
informations on va le vérifier que vous
me dire dans un souci vous savez les
courbes sont entraînés google en ruines
a multiplié en france ce qui était mon a
multiplié par deux la consommation
mérite français n'ont pas encore un
petit peu des barbares la consommation
de charbon gaz charbon vous le savez
très bien c'est terriblement mauvais
pour le climat ils peuvent vous le savez
bien alors le modèle que vous proposez
est un modèle qui en réalité créé une
dépendance hausse morale à gaz et une
dépendance aux centrales à charbon
nonobstant la laideur de ce que vous
proposez parce que je crois que vous
avez proposé deux mille cinq cents
éoliennes
c'est pas la moitié d'ailleurs de la
puissance des vagues que vous vous les
enlevez ce sens c'est pas là vous voulez
des montées c'est pas la moitié de la
puissance des réacteurs que vous voulez
supprimer par ailleurs donc ça c'est pas
connu deux montées je sais pas comment
on va faire vous voulez démonter laissez
moi juste terminée s'est terminée par un
clergé l'habitude de l'être et vous
voulez remplacer dès les éoliennes
actuelles par des éoliennes qui font 200
mètres de haut la tour montparnasse un
partout la tour montparnasse nommé géré
il ya un moment donné quand on se dit
défenseur de l'environnement de
l'écologie je suis navré de vous dire
que les éoliennes de 100 mètres de haut
avec les conséquences que ça sur la
santé humaine sur les animaux les
oiseaux oui oui bien sûr sur les
courants quand elles sont offshore sur
les activités des pêcheurs eh bien ça me
paraît pas raisonnable au delà du fait
que ça nous créé une dépendance que
c'est le visionnement affreux le vent
lui laisser le vent l'effrayant que
c'est effrayant encore une fois pour la
protection de l'environnement c'est un
mauvais choix et la limaille nous
montrent que c'est un mauvais choix
et et le mauvais vous n'avez pas de
problème avec les cent mille pilotes de
ligne tht ça de très haute tension ça
vous trouvé ça très beau dans le paysage
vous n'avez je ne vous ai jamais entendu
non mais vous savez alors qu'ils n'ont
alors que vous connaissez peut-être pas
très bien le sujet mais en fait quand
vous relier des énergies renouvelables
vous n'avez pas de besoin de lignes à
très haute tension ça c'est pour les
réacteurs nucléaire ou les centrales
elle a coûté 100 milliards non non le
raccordement non mais l'énergie madame
le pen intermittente sur le prix vous
n'y arriverez pas il ya un ep qui est en
construction il écoute déjà 20 milliards
il devait coûter 3 milliards mais je
suis surpris vous qui parlez toujours
d'exemplarité en termes de politiques
publiques je ne vous ai jamais entendu
dire que les responsables nucléaires
devaient rendre des comptes pour 17
milliards d'euros de gabegie de
gaspillage de surcoûts dix ans de délai
pour un ep r est ce que vous proposez
c'est de transformer un j'ai un fiasco
en 6 8 ou 14 fiasco comme emmanuel
macron pour une électricité ponote en
2005 anglais sur les centrales à charbon
ce que j'ai quand même une équipe qui
travaille en régie merci va longtemps
sur les centrales à charbon ça très
dernièrement augmenté très légèrement
mais ça n'a pas d'oubli voilà n'ont
qu'un canal a ajouté vous regardez non
mais la cour s'est passé et ce qui m'a
dit où vous regardez on va on va essayer
de la madeleine dix dernières années
vous regardez sur le charbon je veux
dire allez allez sur google regarde des
mix énergétique allemand vous verrez
vous pourrez voir des soirées mal
d'assurance j'ai dit qu'ils on conseille
surtout en allemagne mais en deux ans en
2019 art de l'illusion 2019 parce que ce
sont nos militaires en 2009 mais
certainement pas de musique ça avait
doublé mais non c'est un bon temps j'ai
dit en france voilà quatre ans en
allemagne ce n'est pas en france un peu
plus en 2010 annoncée en france alors
c'est pas énorme mais quand même ça a
doublé donc on voit bien on le sait très
bien d'ailleurs qui aiment jus
dépendance encore une fois au charbon et
au gaz avec les énergies est injuste et
anik jean du rock hotel des marines le
panama c'est un sujet qui est très
important c'est bien qu'on l'abordé
c'est fondamental sur touvre
fondamentale et là exactement et plus en
plus c'est vraiment c'est important de
le faire en ce moment surtout avait avec
ce qui se passait on devait pas
l'aborder je trouve que c'est très bien
qu'on l'abordé j'aimerais juste qu'on
dise un petit mot sur ce qu'ont à dire
on aura moins de temps mais quand même
on jure
voilà on a quand même une guerre en
ukraine qui le démontre quoi que
tchernobyl c'est toujours pas réglé des
décennies après l'accident s'est
toujours pas réglé ça nous a montré que
une centrale nucléaire pouvait devenir
une cible et être bombardées et puis la
moitié de l'uranium que nous importons
vient de l'ex urss vient du kazakhstan
de l'ouzbékistan qui sont contrôlés sous
tutelle de poutine alors je sais que
poutine est votre ami mais moi alors
marange justement ça n'est ce pas
justement femme n'est pas j'aimerais
j'aimerais juste une question
énergétique moi je préfère une dépense
du j'avais des nouvelles de vadim du
soleil de l'eau non mais faut savoir
j'avais essayé d'appeler si vous n'êtes
sûrement mais que moi je moi moi ça moi
je préfère mais ça prend du soleil iris
de l'énergie du soleil ou de la biomasse
plutôt que de poutine suit sécurité ou
du kazakhstan on dépend du gaz avec vos
énergies l'uranium ou du parent du gaz
que vous nous apportez pas de solution
si vous voulez coupé gaz russe très bien
alors il nous apportait pas de solution
moi je n'ai aux émergents messieurs
jadot pavillon et oui mais il faut quand
elle tourne pas vos éolien quand il n'y
a pas de vent et les énergies
renouvelables c'est de l'hydraulique
c'est de la biomasse tiens et de la
jonte s'éloigne de l'éolien du
photovoltaïque et seydou l'éolien c'est
comme ça que les agents hockey du soleil
c'est comme ça qu'est les agences de
l'état nous dise qu'on peut avoir un
scénario en 100% j'ai bien compris vous
voulez faire du nucléaire oui vous
voulez couper les éoliennes la réalité
c'est que votre projet mis en place
c'est la panne électrique dans notre
pays non non non merci hier assis juste
voulu répondre juste à sa marine le pen
ce que c'est vraiment je le redis on
devait parler de chasse mais on encore
et je trouve que ce sujet est
extrêmement important et je trouve que
c'est bien qu'on soit bien que les
aborder ce soir qu un dernier mot
là-dessus marine le pen compte quand
yannick jadot moi je suis désolé de vous
dire que la politique menée par les
écologistes est un peu mort aux pauvres
quoi c'est à dire que je vous rappelle -
très bien en 2013 il ya eu un accord
entre le ps et les verts qui réclamaient
une augmentation très importante du prix
du carburant d'ailleurs emmanuel macouin
fini par le faire oui si vous demandiez
une hausse de 18 centimes du carburant
serre que vous vous ne voyez pas les
conséquences de votre politique sur les
gens le problème c'est que vous disiez
d'ailleurs qu'il fallait aller même au
delà de cela ça qu'il fallait que le
gazole rejoignez vous êtes encore blessé
pour tromper vous êtes vous encore vous
avez vous savez moi ou pas un prix quand
on a commencé à aborder la question de
la taxe carbone j'étais à l'époque à
greenpeace j'ai négocié le grenelle de
l'environnement
on a toujours dit que pour les français
notamment les plus impactés ça devait
compenser à l'euro près et me fait pas
le coup de la réalité des gens chez moi
j'ai un picardie moi je viens d'un
village je suis pas né à saint cloud
dans un château monnaies l'héritage
l'héritage que j'ai lu l'héritage que
j'ai de mes parents maintenant c'est une
entreprise familiale ce sont des valeurs
sont les vases et au public est donc
m'expliquer pas comment en picardie on
vit y compris dans l'année c'est d'avoir
une voiture j'en suis parfaitement
conscient accord mais en même si vous si
vous n'entendez pas que l'objectif des
politiques publiques aujourd'hui ça doit
être de réduire les dépenses de
chauffage d'électricité des français en
les protégeant il ya 12 millions de
français qui cet hiver n'arrive pas se
chauffer et qui auront sûrement très
chaud cet été vous avez des françaises
et des français qui sont coincés avec
des mobilités contraintes moi je met en
place le covoiturage jusqu'à 1000 euros
de carburant remboursés par les
entreprises pour aider au covoiturage on
a je veux mettre 400 euros de chèques
énergie carburant pour les six millions
de familles les plus vulnérables 100
euros pour les familles moyennes
justement pour aider à passer cette
épreuve terrible de l'explosion des prix
m mais ces niches attention climatique
mais monsieur messier jadot part dans
mémoires des métis vous avez en h à st
je suis favorable à une augmentation de
la fiscalité sur le carburant sinon je
ne serais pas écologiste c'est ce que
vous avez dit aujourd'hui une notation
je suis pas le cas mais flottant vous 2
me direz vous êtes en train de me dire
on va faire toute une série dette c'est
à dire qu'en réalité on va demander aux
contribuables de payer pour les
consommateurs mais sont les mêmes
monsieur jadot ce sont les mêmes les
contribuables et les consommateurs de
carburant faute de fuir ce sont les
maîtres rien la conteuse moi je baisse
de 20 à 5,5 de la tva a assuré c'est pas
leur bureau c'est pas l'heure mais je
leur rends monsieur jadot moi et ça
c'est de l'argent public c'est des
retraites n'ont fait mais je ne
comprenais pas qu'un but était chanté ce
qui sort on a un petit souci sur moi je
leur rends cet argent et donc on connait
je veux dire je vais pas leur reprendre
de la main droite ce que je leur donne
de la main gauche je leur en 12 minutes
en laissant le fioul électricité vous
savez le gars s'il vous plaît ne
condamnons pas saturé ça va venir vite
que en fait la mesure que vous allez
appliqué pour une infirmière qui avec
ses clio bénéficiera deux fours - de sa
mesure que quelqu'un qu'un gros et
suivez les 20 % les moins riches dans
notre pays la facture d'énergie c'est
15% pour les 5% les plus riches ces 5%
c'est ben moi je préfère aider celles et
ceux qui souffrent le plus de la hausse
des prix que d'appliquer une règle qui
bénéficiera d'abord aux plus riches qui
va bénéficier à tout prix le litre la
bca bah oui mais de 35 à 50 centimes les
gros suv pardonnez moi c'est pas les
caissières qui qui qui qui conduisent
les gros suv donc vous préférez
valoriser héros et donner plus d'argent
aux plus riches ça m'étonne pas c'est
depuis longtemps votre programme r si
yannick jadot phoenix ado on apprenne
caricature vous allez revenir maintenant
il va la réalité yannick jadot la
semaine prochaine on parlera chasse
parce que là on a explosé mais moi
j'aime ça
jusqu alors et on fait vraiment deux
minutes sur la chasse allez-y parce que
des âmes en deux minutes un oui tout à
fait parce que c'est assez
extraordinaire quand on vous écoute sur
le bien-être animal alors vous valorisez
les chats c'est génial j'en ai aussi je
pense et fait un banal
sauf qu'en fait d'ailleurs la boucle
sans vous demander comment d'ailleurs
donné vous et moi dans leurs projets
alors vous allez voir alors vous vous
c'est vrai on voulait mettre dans la
conseillère de la cause animale
sauf qu'en fait la chasse à courre les
chasser plus cruel vous les supprimez
pas vous êtes contre mais vous les
supprimez pas l'élevage industriel où
les poules vivre toute leur vie dans
l'équivalent de ça vous le supprimez pas
d'heure vous votez contre la suppression
des élevages en cage sans qu'un moment
donné madame leprince simplement faut
avoir un peu de cohérence on peut pas
être pour des animaux même et pour les
chasser mais si je dois être pour les
animaux et l'élevage qui
d'un un truc de souffrance animale
abominable with aussi les ados vous
marine objectivement vous avez tort
j'instruis effectivement dans la
constitution je crains c'est de la chose
ou pour vous inscrire
monsieur jadot je vous en supplie
sa peine en allemagne mais c'est à dire
si c'est vraiment difficile de débattre
avec vous parce que vous allez au bout
d'une idée alors laissez la fait bien
qu'on abat les coûts d'ailleurs de
propositions communes en espèces sur les
animaux y compris moi j'ai ajouté un
lent soldes le statut de lanceurs
d'alert pour dénoncer les maltraitances
aux animaux jeu j'aggrave d'un tiers les
peines les amendes pour la maltraitance
pour les abandons avec ses jets dossier
des associations ce que vous ne faites
pas puisque j'ai pérennise 20 millions
de budget pour les associations de
défense des animaux c'est très bien on
la cherche un château
avoir besoin de ricardo les associés
sont arrivés au pouvoir ce que je ne
crois pas parce que franchement il va
falloir bosser merci message ados
marines up sur la chaîne je pense la
même chose que vous en tout cas ce que
vous pensiez en 2016 qu'est ce que vous
aviez dit à un journal de change
d'ailleurs à savoir qu' on peut être
chasseur et avoir des préoccupations
environnementales que vous connaissez
comme moi des chasseurs qui sont très
responsables vis-à-vis de la faune c'est
ce que vous écriviez la gestion et la
chasse à courre moi je vous dis je pense
que ce sont des sujets sociétaux qui
doivent être que d'autres doivent donc
dont doit se saisir la société c'est par
exemple auquel je crée le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne l'or
sera quoi la question à tout voir les
cds français doivent pouvoir se saisir
d'un sujet et déclencher un référendum
c'est la revendication qui a été porté
par les gilets jaunes nous portons cette
revendication
25 ans sur l'intégralité des sujets mais
celle là ça c'est la revivification de
la démocratie permettre aux français de
se saisir d'un sujet et honnêtement ces
sujets là sont des sujets vraiment de
soucis pour que les français donc on a
dû s'exprimer nos missions d le sujet
des laisser fonctionner terminé sur le
sujet des chasses qui sont spécifiques
qui sont bien souvent d'ailleurs très
limité sur le plan territorial est
très limité d'ailleurs sur vous n'avez
pas qu'à la chasse a dit non non moi ce
que je vois là pour moi mon urgence
pardon je le dis parce que cela ne le
dira pas mon urgence moi c'est
l'abattage sans étourdissement
je veux l'abattage avec étourdissement
parce que ça ce sont quatre millions et
demi de bovins qui sortent chaque année
dans des souffrances monsieur qui se
laisse une battante et terrible moi même
urgence urgence cellule pour d'époque et
non
sur la chasse non mon idée annoncé qu on
ne sait pas mais en tout cas je
trancherai pas ouais l'achat de tels
changera là dessus et quand je fais bush
a décidé de se joindre aux familles qui
vont semer vous tiendrons au respect
mutuel a dit qu'on faisait de lui alors
temps de monsieur nadeau prévoyez la
manière dont vous abordez ça mais parce
qu'à mon enfant mention des transports
mais c'est décidé vous plaît et ça c'est
bien si on n'arrive plus à mettre les
gens à en discuter tranquillement autour
d'une table moi ce que je veux c'est
recréer la concorde ce sont des sujets
des sujets qui sont importants de où il
ya des associations de défense des
animaux il ya des chasseurs or vous avez
hystériser ces débats là non donc on
peut très bien se mettre autour d'une
table il sait dire madame mini jeux pc
jadot
par exemple des usages des forêts
domaniales on va se mettre autour d'une
table et on peut décider que les
chasseurs peuvent chasser le matin et
que l'après midi s'est réservé aux
promeneurs et chaque préfet pourra
déterminer sa de manière la plus précise
possible
département par département est-ce qu'on
peut aller vers la paix la concorde a
souri série c'est le débat non moi je
vais je regrette je lis et vous dis
franchement merci à bout de bras je
pense à ces dames femme de 25 ans qui
est morte il ya quelques semaines et qui
a été tué par une jeune fille de 17 ans
qui avait un fusil entre les mains et
ben oui quand il ya 900 mille chasseurs
et 66 millions de français autres qui
veulent profiter de la nature je choisis
les familles et pas les chasses merci a
déjà versé yannick jadot mais je suis
ado je vous disiez en 2006 à nick jonas
et sur la chasse est déjà organisé en
france associations fédérations bien ses
amis ses plans de gestion cette galère
j'arrêtais j'ai des progrès visibles